[Musique]
par les enfants aux patrons prennent
forme ce soir à miel north en mieux
comme son style je suis jeune que j'ai
envie de faire de plein km qu'ils
obligent méfie-toi nounours qu'il n'en
fasse pas des blagues on le chope
heureux mon le cheveu de fondre fois
colas a pris l'eau je veux leur sillage
les cannes hier rémi toto ifo sachant
malade il faut pas faire de bruit
bonsoir buso lui ferme les yeux pas
probl
non le t2 du poisson d'avril
terrebonne blanche
kemal avec les blacks ne fit pas pour
lui de ce qu'ils se posent
tu nous jugeons malak ils ont les
oreillons
j'aurais l'eau 'le point' blague au delà
fait preuve bouffe fait une farce petit
garnement
mais non et nous sont bien belle affiche
et c'est vrai une opa peu plus
ambitieuse terrible ce shérif most
wanted
[Musique]
on a beau bourg et voilà et bonbons bien
chaud pour régner pourtant et pour ma
femme ils sont très bons avec du miel
duels
nous allons vous en avez de la chance ça
y est je n'étais sûr on relate des
façons c'est parce qu'un médicament nda
sealed air cabine le faire comme ça ils
sont plus vite et rip ils n'auront plus
les arédiens allons mes chéris
prenez vos bons biberon pour faire
plaisir à votre tonton il ne vole voyons
que faut il avoir mené les hausses en
voilà une pâle nous y attend vous pas
tout et vous prenez vos biberons et nous
en vous chaque notre vers 16 d'accord et
voilà tu peux parler à mes 9 ans anna
qu'une bonne nuit non ça demain je pars
tranquille
ils sont bien soigner mes neveux jury au
revoir mais chérubins votre tonton 120
bornes
voici la fin de la journée c'est le
moment de se coucher
nous faisons comme une eau amie née sans
doute ou souli non
l'ours est sur son nuage
j'en suis certain le marchand de sable
via il nous dira fermez vos yeux et
dormait tous les deux nous sommes bien
dans notre lit none of houphouet boigny
sabran ce mois encore fait plaisir quand
je vais m'endormir
quand je vais m'endormir
safra nous fait plaisir
[Musique]
oh
bravo nicolas bravo pape rhône elle je
suis certain que rémi toto et fanfan
vont très vite guérir car vous le
soigner très bien à te voilà nounours
mais didot qu'est ce que tu as dans le
dos aux profs robert bru potro tu vois
il tombe bien attraper une fois de plus
se sont tellement gentils patrons
dommage je voudrais faire un bon jeu
avec eux vous voulez bien d'accord nous
allons en route de nuit des enfants à
demain à gogo
[Musique]
[Rires]